this morning clark county businesses  need to submit their plans to combat the  recent rise in coronavirus cases  clark county commissioners voted to  require those plans last week  they're also requiring employees wear  face masks in public indoor spaces  business owners we spoke with say  they're being cautious  we installed a plexiglass just a way to  protect my  employee and also protect all our guts  that coming in here  usually about like six customers in our  restaurant  and usually we just lock the door or  like they can put the order in that they  came  outside away so this includes  restaurants grocery stores malls and  other indoor venues that host  gatherings of 250 people or more they  had to submit a covet plan earlier this  morning